[Música]
a pesar de sus diferencias internas el
partido republicano cierra filas en
torno al expresidente de Estados Unidos
Donald Trump quien deberá presentarse a
un juzgado de Nueva York el próximo
martes tras ser acusado de cargos
penales
Guatemala reafirma que para ellos Taiwán
es la única y verdadera china Así lo
expresó el presidente de Alejandro
yamatei al recibir a la mandataria
taiwanesa sai & One los detalles los
seremos desde ciudad de Guatemala
nuevos detalles en la investigación por
el incendio en el centro de detención de
migrantes en Ciudad Juárez México una
guardia de seguridad dio por primera vez
una declaración Mientras que el
presidente de Andrés Manuel López
Obrador le pide ayuda a Estados Unidos
Bienvenidos a esta emisión dedicada a
las noticias de América yo soy María
Clara calle
iniciamos en Estados Unidos este viernes
los republicanos cerraron filas en torno
al expresidente Donald Trump luego de
que un juzgado de Nueva York decidiera
acusarlo por un supuesto soborno a la
actriz porno stormy Daniels Es la
primera vez que se acusa a un antiguo
mandatario en ese país Trump comparecerá
ante un tribunal de Manhattan el próximo
martes y es Entonces cuando se conocerán
los cargos específicos que enfrentan así
han reaccionado los republicanos
tras la decisión sin precedentes del
Gran Jurado de acusar al expresidente
Donald Trump los republicanos hacen un
cerco para respaldarlo que fuera su
vicepresidente Mike pence declaró que
todo obedecía a una persecución política
y que la decisión Envía un terrible
mensaje al mundo respecto de la justicia
de su país
Permítame decir que creo que la
acusación sin precedentes de un
expresidente de Estados Unidos por un
tema de financiación de campaña es un
ultraje
y debo decirles Eso debería ser ofensivo
para cada estadounidense izquierda
derecha y centro cada estadounidense
merece el mismo trato bajo la ley y creo
que el pueblo estadounidense verá esto
por lo que es
para el senador republicano Tech Cruz
este proceso es un mal precedente para
el país más precedentes serán procesados
la persecución política de Donald Trump
por parte del fiscal de distrito de
Manhattan Alvin brack Pon Estados Unidos
en un muy mal camino
declaraciones que se suman a las del
gobernador de Florida ron de santis
quien si bien se perfila como el gran
oponente de Trump para ganar la
candidatura republicana de 2024 condenó
la acusación contra el expresidente
la militarización del sistema legal para
promover una agenda política pone patas
arriba al Estado de derecho es anti
estadounidense el fiscal de distrito de
Manhattan respaldado por soros ha
torcido constantemente la ley para
degradar los delitos graves y excusar la
Mala conducta criminal los cargos de la
acusación no se han hecho públicos pero
estarían vinculados al supuesto soborno
a la actriz porno stormy Daniels por
130.000 dólares en plena campaña
presidencial de 2016 se espera que Trump
comparezca ante la justicia el próximo
martes
la presidenta de Taiwán say in one llegó
este viernes a Guatemala y la recibió el
mandatario del país Alejandro yamatei
quien reiteró su apoyo a la isla esto es
justo lo que busca inhuen en su viaje
por Centroamérica desde ciudad de
Guatemala nuestro corresponsal Andrés
Suárez Jaramillo nos cuenta Qué pasó en
el encuentro de los presidentes aquí en
el Palacio Nacional de ciudad de
Guatemala terminó la declaración ante
los medios de comunicación del
presidente Alejandro yamatei y de la
presidenta taiwanesa Sáenz way uno de
los momentos más emotivos ocurrió cuando
el presidente llama té y le recordó a
Taiwán que es la única y verdadera
República de China y cuando se realizó
la traducción al chino mandarín la
delegación taiwanesa irrumpió en
aplausos antes que hablar de acuerdos
bilaterales se recordó porque estas dos
naciones son amigas sobre todo por
compartir valores como la paz la
libertad los derechos humanos y el
respeto integridad territorial
se le vio muy distinto como cuando vino
amlo el año pasado estaba muy alegre y
le dijo que personalmente consideraba la
presidenta de Taiwán como una amiga por
su parte la presidenta taiwanesa elogió
la sabiduría de yamatei por mantener a
este país como uno de los más prósperos
económicamente de latinoamérica le
ofreció las condolencias por la muerte
de los 28 guatemaltecos en el albergue
de Ciudad de Juárez y también le dijo
que sobre todo cuando un amigo extiende
una mano en un momento crítico se
considera una verdadera amistad
de Guatemala pasamos a México donde
avanzan las investigaciones sobre el
incendio en el centro de detención de
migrantes de Ciudad Juárez y que dejó 39
muertos una guardia de seguridad salió
en defensa de las acciones de sus
colegas Mientras que el presidente de
Andrés Manuel López Obrador le pidió a
Estados Unidos que colabore más en las
políticas migratorias mexicanas el
informe es de Rafael Pérez
avanza la investigación Angélica
Hinojosa una de las guardias de
seguridad del centro de detención de
migrantes ubicado en Ciudad Juárez donde
murieron 39 personas habló a la prensa
según ella el encargado de la unidad de
hombres salió del edificio antes de que
se iniciara la conflagración un nuevo
detalle Que cuestiona si el principal
del área de detención masculina quien
además controlaba la llave de acceso a
la cárcel pudo salvar a los detenidos la
llave La resguardan ellos ellos son los
que tienen la llave
Pues no creo que se las haya llevado la
saga de Haber puesto colgada Donde están
todas las llaves Igual nosotros siempre
que Les deseamos hoy es que pues llegó
gente yo digo que las puso ahí Ahí
estaba la llave Nada más que pues nadie
me imagino que nadie corrió la oficial
de guardia pudo rescatar a las mujeres a
su cargo mientras las investigaciones
avanzan el presidente mexicano Andrés
Manuel López Obrador hizo un llamado de
atención a Estados Unidos señaló al
vecino del Norte por su falta de ayuda a
los migrantes para que no sucedan
siniestros como el incendio de esta
semana
lo que hemos pedido al gobierno de
Estados Unidos es que si nosotros
estamos destinando 100 millones de
dólares pónganle ustedes ayuden Y no lo
han hecho ni con el presidente Trump
logramos Esto ni ahora con el presidente
biden este viernes la Secretaría de
Seguridad y protección Ciudadana de
México anunció el cierre definitivo de
la estación de aprehensión donde ocurrió
la catástrofe
la Corte Suprema de Justicia de Perú
ratificó que el expresidente Pedro
Castillo
debes en prisión preventiva
mega por un caso de corrupción así el
máximo tribunal rechazó la apelación que
había presentado la defensa del Antiguo
mandatario sus abogados alegan que no
hay riesgo de que Castillo se fugue y
que Por ende no debería estar en la
cárcel pero la corte no está de acuerdo
y ratificó en cambio la decisión de un
juzgado inferior
y en Chile han aparecido por lo menos
1500 lobos marinos Muertos o agonizantes
en las costas junto con decenas de
Pingüinos estos animales se están
contagiando de la gripe aviar esta
semana las autoridades sanitarias
chilenas reportaron el primer contagio
en un ciudadano chileno Aunque es poco
probable que el virus se transmita entre
personas yo es Muñoz nos amplía
riesgos sanitario en Chile decenas de
lobos marinos están apareciendo muertos
en las costas chilenas la causa la gripe
aviar por ello el municipio de arica
tuvo que cerrar las cuevas de anzota uno
de sus grandes atractivos turísticos
sabemos que esto va a golpear la
economía de un sector importante de
nuestra ciudad sin embargo tenemos un
alto número de cuerpos de lobos marinos
que han muerto producto de la gripe
aviar esto después de que el miércoles
se diese a conocer el primer caso de
gripe había reportado en un humano en
Chile las entidades de salud chilenas
empezaron a vacunar a trabajadores de
granjas estamos acá Evi
llamamos hacemos ese llamado categórico
tenemos ya el primer caso en humano que
es un caso extraño Por lo tanto tenemos
que seguir actuando como lo hemos hecho
hasta ahora el primer contagio en
humanos del último brote se detectó en
una niña en Ecuador en enero las
autoridades señalan que es posible que
el virus se transmita de aves y
mamíferos marinos a humanos pero es rara
la transmisión entre personas granjas
aviares en chile y Argentina detectaron
casos en los últimos meses por lo que
han tenido que detener sus exportaciones
el virus fue descubierto en 2014 en
Norteamérica la organización
Panamericana de la salud alertado de un
fuerte rebrote durante el 2023 siendo
detectado en 10 países de la región
el Ministerio de minas y energía elevó
el nivel de
alerta el Nevado del Ruiz que pasó de
ser amarilla a naranja el servicio
geológico explicó que esto significa que
puede haber una erupción considerable en
los próximos días aunque no es algo
inminente el indicio surge porque los
sismos han aumentado al punto que sólo
el jueves hubo
11.600 una erupción del nevado del Ruiz
este volcán fue la que sepultó al pueblo
de armero en 1985
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con France
[Música]